en el vídeo pasado nos quedamos en lo
siguiente ya habíamos cambiado la fuerza
por el término masa por aceleración y
habíamos dicho que derivando dos veces
la función posición llegábamos a la
aceleración después dijimos que íbamos a
plantear una ecuación diferencial e
íbamos a resolverla entonces justo es lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo va bueno
para plantear nuestra ecuación
diferencial lo que vamos a hacer es
sustituir está aquí arriba en términos
de la segunda derivada entonces vamos a
hacer eso que nos quedaría nos quedaría
que m por aa pero que es x doble prima
de t es igual a menos que por x de t muy
bien aquí ya tenemos nuestra ecuación
diferencial y de qué se trata esto de
las ecuaciones diferenciales bueno pues
en una ecuación normal tenemos algunas
variables relacionadas con una igualdad
y queremos despejar las si queremos
encontrar un numerito aquí no queremos
encontrar un número sino que lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar una función
x dt que satisfaga esto para cualquier
valor de t
o sea la respuesta a una ecuación
diferencial no es un número sino es toda
una función o bien toda una familia de
funciones pero ahorita vamos a pensar en
qué es nada más una función vale y cómo
se hace para resolver estas cosas pues
hay algunos métodos sofisticados en
ecuaciones diferenciales pero nosotros
no tenemos que meternos con esos métodos
por qué pues porque ya tenemos una
intuición que nos dice cómo puede ser la
función va entonces la intuición era más
o menos decir ok esto parece que está
enterándose así que tiene un cierto
periodo y además al principio no es cero
entonces posiblemente tenga que ver con
algo que es como de kossen o de w de
donde está w todavía le dejamos un poco
de libertad
entonces de ahí venía nuestra intuición
entonces eso va a estar padre o sea la
intuición nos permite intentar dar una
propuesta de una función que puede
funcionar bueno qué bueno que puede ser
solución a una función que puede
funcionar con una función que puede ser
solución y ya nada más hay que verificar
si está así como la tenemos cumple o si
hay que pedirle algunas
y bueno pues vamos a hacer eso entonces
estaré aquí es x dt déjame copiarla aquí
abajo entonces tenemos que xd xd t es
igual
aa
a jose no de w jose de w
ok entonces para ver si satisface o no
tenemos que encontrar su segunda
derivada vamos con la primera entonces
déjame tomar el color rosa entonces
quién sería la derivada de x sería x
prima de t y para hacerla vamos a
utilizar la regla de la cadena está a la
voy a dejar aquí afuera porque es una
constante quien es la derivada de lo de
adentro pues adentro tenemos doble ute y
estamos derivando con respecto a t
entonces la derivada sería w
entonces eso es la derivada de lo de
adentro pero hay que multiplicar por la
derivada de lo de afuera o sea la
derivada de coseno que es menos
evaluado en lo de adentro en w
muy bien entonces eso de ahí es la
primera derivada déjame pasar al color
de la segunda derivada y vamos a hacerla
entonces la segunda derivada es derivar
la primer derivada y nos quedaría que x
doble prima de t es igual a aquí hay un
menos lo dejamos el doble también porque
es una constante y ahora la derivada de
seno de w
se vuelve a hacer con regla de la cadena
la derivada de lo de adentro es w voy a
ponerle acción w cuadrada porque este
doble sale multiplicando y hay que
multiplicar por la derivada de seno o
sea por coseno evaluado en lo de adentro
de w
muy bien entonces aquí ya tenemos a x y
a su segunda derivada entonces
necesitamos verificar que se cumpla esta
condición
esta condición de acá la de la ecuación
diferencial vamos a hacer esto aquí
arriba para tener un poco más de espacio
déjame tomar el color amarillo y
entonces vamos a hacer las cuentitas
vamos a ver si de veras m por la segunda
derivada evaluada en t es menos k por x
de t
entonces nos gustaría que m m x menos
- a w cuadrada jose no de
a menos que menos acá por equis dt o sea
por a
jose no de www.hoy.com.ec e podemos
cancelar las con estas de acá verdad
este menos es un -1 entonces cancelamos
el menos a con el menos a y que nos
queda a bueno también podemos cancelar
este el coseno eso es muy bueno porque
ya no va a depender de t y queremos que
la igualdad se dé para todas las para
todos los valores de t entonces para que
se dé la igualdad para todos los valores
de tema ya nada más falta que m por w
cuadrada que m por w cuadrada sea igual
a que nos quedó de este lado nada más la
k
bueno pues la m y la k están dadas por
el problema esas no las podemos cambiar
porque dependen de la masa y de la
constante del resorte pero en donde si
tenemos un montón de libertades en la w
porque estamos poniendo esta propuesta y
podemos poner la w que queramos y bueno
que w es la que necesitamos pues m por
doble un cuadrado es igual acá siempre y
cuando w cuadrado
sea igual a ca / m
/ m y eso lo podemos lograr pidiendo que
w sea igual a raíz cuadrada de k / m
muy bien eso está padrísimo entonces ya
encontramos un valor de w para el cual
nuestra propuesta va a satisfacer la
ecuación diferencial entonces eso está
padrísimo ya tenemos una solución déjame
escribirlo por aquí porque eso es
importante entonces lo que obtenemos lo
que obtenemos es que la solución para
esta ecuación diferencial es x voy a
ponerlo más bonito
xd xd t igual a a a- es hasta donde
estiramos la masa a jose no de w con
este valor de w que es raíz cuadrada de
k / m x t muy bien entonces aquí ya
tenemos una función que satisface la
ecuación diferencial y por lo tanto pues
en verdad es una función que nos da la
posición
de la masa he dado el tiempo que lo
dejamos moviéndose entonces esto está
súper padre verdad esto ya nos ayuda
para saber dónde estamos y entonces no
sé si si tengo toda la información o sea
a me indica y tú me dices no se animen
dónde está el resorte después de 10
segundos entonces yo puedo sustituir
toda esta información en esta ecuación y
eso me da la posición y sus 12 así ves
si tiene mucho sentido verdad porque o
sea la masa siempre está entre a y menos
al entonces va a ir oscilando y esta
expresión también porque cosenos y la
entre menos uno y uno entonces estoy acá
también se mueve entre menos a y a bueno
esto está padrísimo vamos a ver algunas
consecuencias de esta ecuación en el
siguiente video en donde hablaremos de
periodos y de frecuencias y quizás un
poquito acerca de la velocidad de la
masa sale bueno nos vemos hasta la
próxima